MICHEL DEGRAFF: So why the
personal in this course?
Well, at every occasion
when the students present
their discussions--
because they often
have a friendly discussion-- or
when they write their essays,
I do ask them to include
some personal information
in what they write.
In fact, one essay was
strictly about that,
about their linguistic
biographies.
Because I feel
that often students
can be overly ambitious.
Of course, there's this
earnestness that we appreciate,
but often they want to
go after global changes
like changing the
environment or changing
the outcome of elections.
But those are the kind of
changes that you often cannot
make, especially not in
a one semester course.
But if they are able
to understand the way
those global patterns affect
their own personal lives
in their own small
social groupings,
and if they can actually try
to integrate what they learn
in the course to actions
in these localized spheres,
then there's a better chance
that they can actually
make those changes.
So I like to tell them
that the change that they
can make in themselves
resolving those issues
are also affecting
the wider world.
Because if each person
can affect themselves
in their small
groups and, in turn,
if everyone in that small
group can also affect changes
in their own small groups,
then the effect is exponential.
You see?
And I think by the end of
the course they do appreciate
being able to share their
personal experiences
through essays, through
their presentations.
And also they can see
the effect that this
has on their own
classmates, because some
of their classmates come from
very different backgrounds.
So they get to understand
how someone, say,
from Guatemala
who came to the US
with parents that
emigrated without papers
and how that life
experience can be inspiring,
because if you can make
it to MIT with that kind
of background and then
you can actually share it
with others while you are
actually succeeding as an MIT
student, that can be life
changing for some of us.